Awesome.
[Music]
Uh, hi everyone. My name is Tomas. I'm
one of the co-founders of Graphite.
Graphite is an AI code review uh,
company.
So to give some context on sort of where
we see the industry right now and where
we see it going. Software development
currently and has always had two loops.
The inner loop which is focused on
development and the outer loop that's
focused on review. Developers spend time
in the inner loop. They get their code
working. They get the feature the way
they want it and then they go ahead and
they move it to the outer loop where
it's tested, reviewed, merged, deployed.
We're seeing the inner loop change right
now more than we've ever seen it. More
developers are using AI than ever. I
think right here we have some statistics
from the GitHub developer survey. Nearly
every developer surveyed used AI tools
both inside and outside of work. And 46%
of GitHub is being written by cop code
on GitHub is being written by C-pilot.
We're seeing more and more code being
written by AI. Here we have some
statistics around how code has changed
over time and how some people predict it
will change. And even if we take a more
pessimistic view of that, we still see
the way the world's going as just more
and more and more code being written by
AI.
The inner loop is changing. You know, AI
is making more uh developers more
productive. Developers now producing
higher volumes of code, but that code
still needs to be reviewed. When we
first started looking at this, when we
first started building uh Diamond, our
AI code reviewer about a year ago now,
what we found was we read a lot of
articles that scared us a lot. We were
seeing within our own organization a lot
of developers adopting AI tools. But we
were also seeing a problem. AI can
hallucinate. It can make mistakes and
almost more scarily it can make security
vulnerabilities.
For us, what we saw was that while the
inner loop was getting sped up by AI,
the outer loop was rapidly becoming the
bottleneck. Um, we were seeing tools
like cursor, windsurf, copilot, vzero,
bault, all of those producing larger
volumes of code than we were used to,
than we had ever seen before. But we
were also seeing our developers suddenly
have to review higher volumes of code,
test higher volumes of code, merge
higher volumes of code, and deploy
higher volumes of code.
That's what brought us to say, there has
to be a new outer loop here. This the
way that things are going, this isn't
going to work. We're going to break
down. We're watching the problems that
used to only aail large companies start
to aail all companies where we were
seeing companies deal with higher and
higher and higher volumes of code. The
requirements for the new outer loop then
look a lot like the problems that larger
companies have always had to deal with.
You need tools to better prioritize,
track, and get notified about pull
requests. You need driver assist
features to help reviewers focus and
streamline the code review process. You
need optimized CI pipelines and merge
cues to be able to handle the sheer
volume of code changes that are now
happening. and you need better
deployment tools.
Um, when we first started looking at
this through sort of an AI first lens,
we started to see that well the problems
are being created by AI, they can also
probably be solved by AI. We can
probably start to streamline a lot of
these processes which have previously
had been manual, previously were parts
of the process that developers did not
enjoy, did not want to do. Um, we wanted
to see self-driving code review
solutions where we no longer had to do
those very manual and painful parts of
review, but we could actually start to
really focus on what matters most to the
developers, making sure that your
product can get out to users and that
the features work as expected. Um, we
were seeing that AI generated feedback
wasn't perfect and because of that, we
were starting to think that bots weren't
enough. I think an early an early vision
of ours was well, can we solve this by
just adding AI teammates, right? Maybe
it's background agents, maybe it's
reviewers, maybe it's a whole lot of
teammates to the workflow. And while we
think that's part of the story, we don't
think that's enough. We think that, as
we've built with Diamond, that your
entire tool chain has to be AI native,
not just your IDE. If you really are
going to embrace AI in the age of
development if you're going to accept
the fact that developers are going to be
orders of magnitude more productive than
they ever have before, you need tooling
that reflects that.
We started by building diamond so the
winning AI code review platform with
high signal low noise has a deep
understanding of the codebase and change
history. We summarize, prioritize and
review each change and we integrate with
your CI and your testing infrastructure
to correct uh to summarize errors and
correct failures. Um,
our hope with it and what we've started
to see as we've rolled it out to larger
and larger customers and enterprises too
is we re we reduce code review cycles,
we enforce quality and consistency, and
we keep your code private and secure.
Um, it's high signal, it's zero setup,
it's actionable with oneclick
suggestions, and it's customizable. It's
already being used by some of the
fastest moving companies in the world.
It's expanding a lot more than we can
even say publicly. Um, and I hope that
you all will embrace the idea that AI
can change your entire developer
workflow, not just your IDE. Um, by the
numbers, we see comments that our AI bot
leaves to be downloaded at less than a
4% rate and to be accepted, meaning
integrated into the poll request um,
that they were left on at a higher rate
than human comments are. Human comments
are integrated about somewhere between
45 and 50%. We're watching our diamond
comments be accepted about 52%. We've
spent a lot of time tuning that. That's
that number is actually new as of March
for us. Um, that's that's what I have to
tell you around graphite. Um, what I
have to tell you around diamond. I hope
you give it a shot and and thanks for
having me.
[Music]